- Your father, obviously, Kirk Douglas,
everybody loves as well,
but he passed away before the pandemic.
So, what's the best
advice he ever gave you?
Because I always get nervous
about my kids wanting
to be in this industry.
I'm happy for them if they want to do it.
But I imagine he might've
been a little nervous
'cause he knew all the ins and outs of it.
So did he ever give you any good advice?
- Yeah, he was nervous.
I think he knows, you know,
we deal with it, high, high unemployment
in our performance or performers.
Yeah, I guess the best advice he gave me,
I'll have to clean it up a little bit,
(everyone laughs)
but he says, "Look, you gotta do,
"if you do the best you can,
"you just know and you walk
away from the best you can.
"And when you walk away,
you just say (beep) it."
(everyone laughs)
(audience applauds)
- That's awesome.
- And that was pretty
much it for me, you know?
So I said just know you gave it your full.
- Yeah.
- So he, you know, he was 103.
We lost him last year, February, so,
- Yeah.
- it was a good time.
You're gonna go, it was a good time.
He missed all of that.
And then I just two weeks ago, his wife,
my stepmother, Anne, but
Anne was my stepmother
for 63 years.
- Wow!
- So I've known her very well
and she passed away and I
was very, very fond of her.
Stepparents sometimes, you know, they get
a bad rap and
- It can be a thankless job.
- I'm just...it can be a thankless job.
And, you know, for those stepparents
and I had a great stepfather too.
And actually the four of them,
my mother and stepfather,
and Kirk and my stepmother,
they used to get together,
the four of them,
preferably without the kids,
to have a meal, they got
along really, really well.
- What?
- But I like to put a big plug in there.
Yeah, They got along wonderfully,
- Wow!
- wonderfully well, enjoyed
each other's companies
and got to complain about the kids.
(audience laughs)
So that was a good situation.
- Yeah, absolutely.